[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi de novembre voici le
programme samedi 5 novembre
l'association Handicap Société inter
organise une rencontre à Plaisir
principalement à destinée aux proches
qui aident des personnes en situation de
handicap le but trouver des solutions
afin d'améliorer leurs conditions
sociales lutter contre la discrimination
c'est aussi l'objectif de radio
sensation récemment ils ont organisé une
table ronde à Berlin pour faire évoluer
l'image des personnes en situation de
surpoids un projet en partenariat avec
la Maison de l'Europe des Yvelines est
soutenue par le fond citoyen
franco-allemand en France comme en
Allemagne un adulte sur deux étant
surpoids et victime de discrimination
nous en parlerons avec nos invités
Franck et d'art et Corentin Alonso qui
mercredi 10 sorties ciné nous ferons le
point sur les films à ne pas manquer
dans les prochains jours nous partirons
également à la découverte du premier
quiz game des Yvelines avec blind test
et question de culture générale et enfin
nous irons du côté de Poissy focus sur
la nouvelle exposition du Musée du Jouet
et avec moi en plateau Frank et d'arbres
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
vice-président de la Maison de l'Europe
des Yvelines et Corentin Alonso bonsoir
vous êtes journaliste chez Radio
sensation et donc j'en parlais il y a
quelques instants vous avez organisé à
Berlin la semaine dernière une table
ronde sur le thème des personnes en
situation de surpoids alors première
question pourquoi ce choix alors on a
répondu à un appel à projet du fond
citoyen franco-allemand et ça fait déjà
plusieurs plusieurs années que l'on fait
des des rendez-vous des émissions avec
le fond citoyen et cet appel à projet
toucher les diversités et on s'est dit
qu'on allait faire quelque chose autour
de du surpoids de l'obésité des
discriminations qui sont liées à
l'obésité et également et ben essayer de
donner des conseils pour mieux manger
parce que parfois l'obésité ça passe
aussi par par mieux manger et ça permet
d'avoir des repas plus équilibrés et de
lutter contre le surpoids et puis on a
parlé aussi de grossophobie des
discriminations dont les personnes ont
surpoids sont parfois victimes et donc
on en parlera dans quelques instants
avec moi également au plateau Grégory
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde nous parler de
cinéma absolument mercredi qui dit
mercredi elle dit sortie cinéma on va
parler notamment alors à quelques jours
des commémorations les attentats et 13
novembre du 13 novembre 2015 il y a un
nouveau film justement sur les attentats
qui va sortir c'est vous n'aurez pas ma
haine un film qui est adapté un du roman
d'Antoine Leiris on parlera également
côté film français du nouveau film de
Nicolas Bedos et enfin un film à vous
donner parce que on est toujours dans la
période d'Halloween donc un film qui
fait un peu fremia à suivre tout à
l'heure et ce sera donc en seconde
partie d'émission mais avant tout ça je
vous propose de regarder un peu la météo
de demain
demain matin le ciel sera assez dégagé
dans l'ensemble sauf à Mantes-la-Jolie
ou les nuages seront bien présents au
niveau des températures comptées 11
degrés à Rambouillet 12 degrés à Houdan
et Versailles et 13 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi
prévoyait des averses sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera très à 14 degrés en moyenne
et demain nous fêterons les huberts
actualités locales sport santé voici les
informations du jour avec Nicolas
d'André
la situation est compliquée dans tous
les services pédiatriques des hôpitaux
franciliens et notamment dans les
Yvelines le niveau d'activité est très
élevé les professionnels assure tout de
même une prise en charge dans l'ensemble
des sites à noter la solidarité entre
les professionnels de santé libéraux et
les hôpitaux en cas de symptômes chez
votre enfant passer par le 15 pour
assurer l'orientation médicale la plus
juste le futur gestionnaire de l'Espace
Rambouillet est connu il s'agit de la
société wild connexion une décision
suite à la concertation entre l'Office
national des forêts et les acteurs
politiques du sud-yvelines l'Espace
Rambouillet est un espace animalier pour
découvrir la faune forestière où il
connection va signer une concession de
service pour une durée de 30 ans cette
opérateur prévoit notamment d'investir 8
millions d'euros réouverture prévue le 7
avril 2023 le Pass Culture permet
désormais de s'abonner au réseau de
médiathèque de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
depuis le 1er novembre les jeunes de 15
à 18 ans en habitant ou une étudiant pas
dans les douze communes du territoire
peuvent utiliser leurs fonds rattachés
au Pass Culture pour rappel ce
dispositif d'État permet de favoriser
l'accès à la culture pour les plus
jeunes
rejoindre l'incubateur de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines c'est l'objet de l'appel à
candidature actuellement en cours
jusqu'au 25 novembre les entrepreneurs
qui rejoignent le ski cube bénéficient
d'un accompagnement à travers un
programme d'incubation ou d'accélération
objectif favoriser le développement de
startups sur le territoire enfin le
chiffre du jour 18 pour la 18e sélection
pour Emily Boulard livlinois sera
titulaire samedi au poste derrière pour
la demi-finale de la Coupe du monde de
rugby face à la Nouvelle-Zélande la
joueuse native de Rambouillet a joué
l'ensemble des rencontres du Mondial
avec le 15 de France féminin elle s'est
notamment illustrée lors du dernier
match contre l'Italie d'ailleurs la
presse néo-zélandaise désigne Emily
Boulard comme une des potentielles
menaces pour la demi-finale des Black
fermes
et comme d'habitude si vous avez vu une
information ou quelque chose qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous le partager avec le hashtag 78 news
trouver des solutions pour améliorer les
conditions sociales des personnes en
situation de handicap voici la
thématique de la prochaine rencontre
organisée par l'association Handicap
Société inter elle se déroulera samedi
prochain à la salle de la mosaïque à
Plaisir quel est le programme quels sont
les objectifs on regarde l'interview
express de dakoffirme un domoro
président de l'association
[Musique]
notre association a pour but objectif
pour défendre les personnes les droits
des personnes en situation d'handicap et
lutter contre l'isolement des personnes
en situation d'handicap l'insérer de la
société parce que nous disons que le
handicap il est physique intellectuel
psychologique à tous les niveaux donc il
faut que les personnes en situation
handicap physique visible soit bien
traité par la société et soit inséré
dans la société et reconnu comme tel
parce que nous sommes tous des êtres
humains à part entière
c'est d'abord effectivement sensibiliser
rencontrer parents qui ont des enfants
en situation d'handicap voient leurs
difficultés et pouvoir les orienter
parce que nous avons
reçu des personnes des parents qui ont
des soucis d'orienter là en France qui
est en situation d'handicap donc nous
nous recherchons voilà les besoins et
pour les accompagner correctement pour
leur exceptions dans la vie sociale
le programme c'est le ballon déjà la
cérémonie démarre à 15h la réception des
invités et
15h15 la présentat le discours du
président la prestation du poète qui
sera là et après cette prestation il y
aura l'échange avec les parents pour
recueillir les besoins
aussi les personnes en situation
d'handicap pour pouvoir réellement
connaître savoir les besoins pour que la
handicace souhaitait tous les
accompagner auprès des autorités
compétentes
radio sensation et la Maison de l'Europe
des Yvelines ont organisé la semaine
dernière une table ronde au Centre
français de Berlin liberté égalité
obésité c'était le titre de cette table
ronde le but faire évoluer l'image des
personnes en situation de surpoids alors
Franck edar est-ce qu'il y a encore trop
de discrimination aujourd'hui sur les
personnes en situation de surpoids
on l'a vu à travers cette cette table
ronde à travers les témoignages qu'on a
pu avoir alors vous le disiez en
préambule dans cette émission c'est un
adulte sur deux près d'un adulte sur
deux qui se trouve en situation de
surpoids en France comme en Allemagne
d'où l'intérêt de cette de cette table
ronde un quart des adultes sont obèses
en Europe donc il y a vraiment une
problématique autour de l'obésité et
ça se voit quelqu'un qui déborde d'amour
c'est comme ça je dirais quelqu'un qui
est gros c'est quelqu'un qui déborde
d'amour généralement et ben forcément ça
va créer de la discrimination le regard
des autres est parfois difficile à
supporter il y a parfois de la cruauté
il y a très rarement de la bienveillance
vis-à-vis des des gens qui sont qui sont
obèses qui sont en situation de surpoids
on en parle pas assez de la grossophobie
on parle d'autres d'autres choses mais
la grossophobie c'est quelque chose qui
à mon sens et à travers la discussion
qu'on a pu avoir avec Anne-sophie jolie
qui est la présidente du Collectif
National des associations d'obèses avec
Magloire aussi c'est quelque chose qui
est qui est une espèce de normalité on
se moque des gens différents et on se
moque très facilement des gens qui sont
gros sans se préoccuper de la souffrance
que ça peut engendrer et comment faire
du coup pour réduire cette
discrimination pour réduire ses
moqueries alors ça passe par de
l'éducation tout simplement c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on a dit à travers
cette table ronde qui a eu lieu au
Centre français de Berlin vous vous le
disiez l'éducation et puis aussi il y a
le mieux manger ça c'était la deuxième
partie de de l'atelier de cette non on
sait plus bien manger d'ailleurs j'ai
j'ai pris quelques notes il y a un
rapport de l'OMS qui dénonce ce qu'on
appelle un environnement qui est
obésogène alors qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est un accès illimité à la nourriture
c'est un marketing de l'industrie
agroalimentaire qui est assez qui est
assez fort c'est le changement des modes
de vie et puis c'est aussi tout ce qui
est environnement numérique on a tout
apporté le main on a les jeux vidéo donc
généralement quand on est sur son canapé
en train de jouer aux jeux vidéos et ben
on va manger des barres chocolatées il y
a aussi l'aspect les plats transformés
on a pu forcément l'habitude de faire la
cuisine on a la flemme parfois
de prendre des produits des produits
transformés des plats préparés plutôt
que de se faire la cuisine enfin je dis
c'est plus simple pas forcément faut
s'astreindre faut c'est aussi une
question d'éducation et du coup est-ce
qu'il faut faire aussi plus de
sensibilisation à l'école alors
sensibilisation à l'école sans doute à
travers la lutte contre la grossophobie
et puis aussi peut-être aussi du mieux
manger on a on a eu des exemples à
travers la table ronde de témoignages je
pense qu'on en écoutera tout à l'heure
un extrait mais le
Magloire et le cross Varo qui animateur
anim leur télé qui est aussi réalisateur
a fait donc un court métrage avec des
jeunes de Tarnos qu'il a rencontré qu'il
a rencontré là-bas ils ont fait un
court-métrage qui s'appelle grossophobia
et qui traite justement de cette de
cette évolution de la grossophobie alors
ça part du cocon parental et puis à
l'école le regard des autres à l'école
et puis le les adultes qui vont pas
forcément dire attention là tu es en
train de dire du mal de ton petit copain
il peut mal le prendre à attention ta
copine elle voudrait bien faire partie
de ce club de sport malheureusement bah
tu l'as mise de côté bah tu devrais pas
en fait faut pas faut pas montrer les
gens du doigt faut les accompagner faut
les aider et faire preuve de
bienveillance et justement on va
regarder un extrait lors de cette table
ronde vous avez interrogé plusieurs
personnes victimes de grossophobie dont
ma gloire et je vous propose de regarder
un extrait il se trouve que malgré ma
toute petite notoriété c'est par mon
côté obèse que l'on a pu s'attaquer à
moi sur les réseaux sociaux et puis face
à moi à plusieurs reprises et c'est
toujours la chose qui me touche le plus
et pendant des années je me suis
retrouvé comme un petit garçon de 7 ans
face à des attaques j'allais dans une
faire une émission dans une immense
radio bien connue en France une première
et dans cette radio
à l'entrée à l'accueil un garçon que je
connais très bien d'ailleurs qui lui est
plutôt sympathique il mettait plutôt
sympathique mais qui est président la
gloire tu es encore bouffé le chien tu
as encore bouffé du chien c'est vraiment
une expression forte enfin c'est des
mots forts il y a d'autres mots comme ça
marquants qui on en a parlé avec ma
gloire on se connaît depuis l'époque du
Morning Live vous n'étiez peut-être pas
né ces techniques à Lyon sur sur M6 on
en a reparlé alors ça fait partie des
petites phrases c'est de la blague sauf
qu'il y a certains moments cette blague
ça passe mal parce que il y a un
contexte et là en l'occurrence quand
cette personne croise ma gloire dans les
de cette radio et lui fait cette
réflexion ça tombe pas au bon moment et
c'est vraiment très maladroit et c'est
vraiment très blessant et à travers son
court-métrage on voit aussi plein de
petites ouais des petites piques non
mange pas ça t'es déjà assez gros ah
mais ne fais pas ça dépêche-toi cours
mais pourquoi tu cours pas tu as qu'à
moi manger c'est pas uniquement le
l'obésité il y a pas une forme d'obésité
il y a plusieurs obésité chacun peut
être concerné à différents titres il y a
des gens qui pour qui ça va être oui
l'alimentation qui va être un problème
pour d'autres ça va être un problème
plus on va dire génétique mais il y a
différentes formes d'obésité et il y a
pas une solution Corentin il y a des
témoignages qui vous ont marqué vous
aussi c'est surtout les témoignages de
personnes qui ne sont pas obèses puisque
je me reconnais plus dans ce livre
j'avais le pâtissier Christophe
lefeuille qui lui nous expliquait que
dans ces cours de pâtisserie à aucun
moment il n'avait pris en compte c'est
problématiques et donc ça cette table
ronde et que ça lui permettait donc de
faire réfléchir énormément sur ces
questions et donc de réfléchir notamment
à la saisonnalité aussi des des fruits
et des légumes comment s'adapter et puis
comment on peut essayer de réduire les
quantités est-ce qu'il faut faire la
guerre au sucre ou pas est-ce qu'il est
qu'elles alternatives est-ce qu'il peut
peut y avoir toutes ces questions que
finalement ils ne se posaient pas avant
du coup est-ce qu'il faut faire la
guerre au sucre ce qu'il faut le bannir
tout le débat de notre table ronde il y
a eu un grand débat je vous invite à
l'écouter sur sur notre chaîne YouTube
mais donc selon Christophe Lefel on a
fait un peu trop la guerre au sucre et
il faudrait éventuellement réduire les
quantités mais pas non plus sans passer
c'est tout de même important il y a eu
la guerre au gras à un moment on a dit
que le gras c'était pas bien maintenant
c'est le sucre après tout est question
de toutes les questions de quantité et
je pense que les nutritionnistes aussi
qu'on a interrogé autour de cette table
ronde est-ce qu'elle est-ce qu'elle nous
dise c'est que
on peut manger tout
mais faut faire attention aux quantités
donc oui effectivement faire attention
la quantité qui fait le poison
faut pas dépasser Grégory donc moi je
voulais revenir sur le témoignage de
Magloire est-ce que pour lui on l'a
entendu utiliser sa notoriété c'est
important pour lui pour peut-être faire
progresser aussi cette cause et parler
d'obésité il y a très peu de on va dire
de personnes qui représentent ces
personnes obèses il y a pas vraiment de
de stars entre guillemets de porte
drapeau pour pour porter ses
problématiques donc ma gloire souhaite
le faire en tout cas c'est tout à son
honneur et donc il nous disait aussi
qu'il était en train de de réfléchir
donc de d'avoir un nouveau projet de
sortir un nouveau film grossophia phobie
à 2 qui ont que devrait sortir l'année
prochaine
mais mais oui c'est quelque chose
aujourd'hui il manque de et donc de star
entre guillemets il manque de star mais
aussi un manque de
prise de conscience des pouvoirs publics
vous connaissez le slogan Manger Bouger
que l'on voit parfois à la fin des
publicités ou autre mais il y a une
vraie problématique autour du surpoids
autour de l'obésité qui n'est pas
forcément prise en compte par les
pouvoirs publics on cherche toujours à
faire des économies dans les systèmes de
systèmes de santé effectivement prendre
en charge une personne obèse ça coûte
cher il y a des traitements etc mais
parfois vous aurez mieux en fait prendre
le problème entre guillemets à la racine
et essayer d'éduquer les gens sur
comment mieux manger quelles quantité
quel produit à quel moment plutôt que de
se retrouver avec des gens qui sont en
situation de surpoids en obésité on
obésité morbide et pour qui oui ça va
coûter cher les traitements seront
lourds il y aura une souffrance aussi
psychologique mais là il est trop tard
justement dans cette table ronde vous
parlez des médecins et notamment du fait
que les médecins ne sont pas forcément
bien informés c'est le cas même les
médecins ne sont pas forcément formés de
son il n'y a pas de cursus dans les
écoles de médecine dédiées
spécifiquement à l'obésité alors que la
plupart des patients sont atteints de
cette pathologie et c'est ce que
dénonçait Anne-Sophie Joly la présidente
du Collectif National des associations
de baise on a aussi projeté lors de
cette table ronde un autre court-métrage
qui s'appelle courage qui a été réalisé
par une nutritionniste suisse de Munich
et qui parle de cette problématique en
fait c'est que quand la personne en
surpoids va se présenter à son médecin
dans ce dans ce qu'on mettra cette
personne explique qu'elle a mal elle a
mal au cou
première séquence le médecin lui bah oui
mais c'est à cause de votre surpoids
c'est tout et puis ensuite cette
personne on va lui prendre l'attention
sauf qu'une personne obèse bah elle a
des bras un peu plus un peu plus fort
que que les que les nôtres donc le
matériel n'est pas adapté donc on l'a
réprimande deuxième volet du
court-métrage le pas le le médecin
s'interroge ok vous êtes en situation de
surpoids c'est une chose vous avez mal
au cou mais est-ce que vous n'avez pas
apporté une charge lourde est-ce que
vous avez fait un effort est-ce que vous
avez fait quelque chose en fait le
médecin aujourd'hui va lui aussi d'une
certaine façon faire preuve de
de discrimination on va faire va être
maladroit et pas toujours trouver les
mots pour prendre en charge une personne
en situation en situation d'obésité et
donc au-delà de cette table ronde vous
avez aussi réaliser une émission qu'on
peut retrouver sur votre site internet
et sur vos réseaux sociaux c'est ces
émissions et ses tables rondes sont
financées par le fond citoyen
franco-allemand qui met en lumière les
projets favorisant l'amitié
franco-allemande en Europe et l'Europe
est-ce que vous avez d'autres émissions
à venir sur d'autres thématiques
elle est vraiment dans le cadre d'un
projet global la 49 sensation et le fond
citoyen franco-allemand donc il y a eu
cette émission sur l'obésité donc à
Berlin il y aura aussi tout un tas
d'autres émissions donc on est en
partenariat aussi avec la radio clan
break une radio allemande donc ils vont
venir à Élancourt dans notre studio
faire des émissions aussi sur les
clichés qui peut exister entre les enfin
les Français sur les Allemands et les
Allemands sur les Français on ira aussi
là-bas à shuff and Burg donc la ville
qui est jumelée avec
Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc pour
également faire une émission sur la
ville sur des thèmes sur les
discriminations sur l'environnement
aussi on aura une autre émission
spéciale défense sur les questions de
défense avec avec donc le record la
présentation de le record un escadron
donc franco-allemand qui vient au départ
franco-allemand mais finalement il y a 6
nations cadres avec l'Espagne Luxembourg
la Pologne aussi qui la région récemment
donc tout sur les projets européens et
enfin possible une interview de
l'ambassadeur d'Allemagne et donc toutes
ces interviews donc seront diffusés au
fond donc au long tout au long du mois
donc de novembre décembre janvier pour
arriver jusqu'au donc au 22 janvier et
donc les 60 ans du traité de l'Élysée
qui s'élève les relations
franco-allemand très rapidement je crois
que vous avez intégré aussi au projet
des sens à Reporters c'est ça exactement
donc de l'école journaliste de
Montpellier qui qui nous aideront et qui
nous ont aidés donc à faire des
micro-trottoirs sur les relations
franco-allemandes et à réfléchir aussi
avec eux sur toutes ces questions merci
à vous deux d'être venu en plateau
franguidard et Corentin Alonzo donc on
vous souhaite beaucoup de démission et
d'interview on va parler nature
maintenant face aux questions qui se
posent sur la gestion de nos forêts les
agents de l'Office national des forêts
de toute l'Île de France ont organisé
une rencontre avec les Franciliens dans
les Yvelines les 7 forêts domaniales ont
répondu présente nous nous sommes rendus
dans celle de Port-Royal regardez
pourquoi coupez-vous autant d'arbres
cette question les agents de l'Office
National des Forêts l'ont déjà
pratiquement tous entendus c'est
pourquoi face aux interrogations sur la
gestion des forêts l' ONF organisait une
rencontre avec les Franciliens c'est
informé et accueillir le public en forêt
pour expliquer le rôle de l'ONF
puisqu'il y a des polémiques un peu en
particulier sur les coupes de bois et
sur la chasse sur
les dérèglement climatique sur la voilà
c'est tous ces thèmes que l'on peut
aborder et qu'il se qu'ils seront
abordés au bon vouloir de aux questions
des des promeneurs dans la forêt
domaniale de Port-Royal un point de
rencontre était proposé au parking du
Manet une petite dizaine de participants
étaient au rendez-vous il y a des choses
que je connaissais mais il y a plein de
choses que je connaissais pas
la filière du bois là c'est que je me
suis reposer la question souvent quand
je passais là où elle est finir ce bois
là et j'ai vu les machines des fois
tourner sans sans les
parce qu'on a vu des informations
détaillées et concrètes sur comment on
fait concrètement ça j'ai trouvé ça j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant et depuis 5
ans la coupe se fait de façon
irrégulière les agents forestiers
choisissent arbres par arbre selon
différents critères en fonction donc de
ces capacités à croître encore ou est-ce
qu'il est arrivé à maturité et enfin de
vie et en fonction de sa conformité
c'est à dire la couronne le tronc la
couronne de l'arbre si elle est très
étriquée s'il prend trop de place si et
en fonction de ce que l'on veut obtenir
au sol si il empêche une régénération ou
si il va favoriser d'autres arbres le
bois coupé est ensuite dispatché en deux
catégories le bois d'oeuvre et le bois
d'industrie ce dernier est utilisé en
général pour le en dehors de la
production de bois l'ONF a d'autres
rôles comme la préservation de
l'environnement et de la biodiversité
et c'est l'heure maintenant de passer à
notre partie loisir
[Musique]
et nous avons été rejoints plateau par
eili bonsoir bonsoir vous travaillez
pour Enigma 78 escape game Maurepas et
vous venez d'ouvrir le premier quiz game
des Yvelines alors quel est le principe
est très simple vous allez tout
simplement un studio comme à la télé
vous avez un écran énorme géant et vous
avez un animateur virtuel en face vous
avez ces pupitre une personne par
pupitre et le but c'est de répondre aux
questions qui se déroulent sur l'écran
l'écran du coup vous avez plusieurs
thèmes je suppose vous avez des sujets
qui sont les séries des séries télé vous
pouvez avoir le cinéma vous pouvez avoir
le sport c'est des choses assez basiques
et vous avez aussi 60 thèmes et vous et
ça se joue sur 9 manches on a le choix
du coup si on fait un thème on peut
switcher sur un autre la fois d'après
c'est même plus facile que ça étant
donné que la personne qui est en retard
sur le sur le jeu elle peut choisir le
thème qui lui conv pour le mieux vous
aurez effectivement rattrapé ce rata son
retard et du coup c'est accessible à
tout le monde accessible à tout le monde
aux enfants à partir d'un moment qu'ils
sachent lire il y a pas de il y a pas de
souci et même pour les enfants de savoir
qu'il y a une un mode spécial enfant
donc vous allez avoir des Pikachu vous
allez avoir Pixar Disney des petites
choses comme ça vous avez démarré il y a
pas très longtemps 10 jours à peine
quels sont les retours les premiers
retours les gens sont contents
absolument ils sont ravis radis c'est
vraiment quelque chose de nouveau
j'espère qu'il était attendu en tout cas
le retour sont plutôt excellents
on verra par la suite si le temps nous
donne raison pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez décidé de vous lancer dans ces quiz
game et pas seulement dans les escape
game pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé d’étendre votre offre les escapes
c'est du loisir ce que le quiz c'est
dans la continuité un petit peu
différente qu'on puisse proposer
différents choix dans le même mur dans
enceinte et je pense que c'est que
quelque chose qui a été attendu aussi
tout simplement c'est un moment très
convivial ça peut être familial entre
amis il faut
c'est pas très intellectuel ça reste
quand même assez les questions ils sont
assez simples et vous passez vraiment un
moment en famille ou entre amis vraiment
assez exceptionnel il y en a beaucoup en
France où c'est en train de s'éteindre
non il y en a pas énormément mais
effectivement on risque d'en trouver les
projets que à venir en mettre je pense à
ces nombreux et donc on peut venir à
combien c'est des groupes de combien de
personnes alors vous pouvez jouer à
partir de 3 et on peut aller jusqu'à 6
et du coup vous l'avez un petit peu
expliqué le déroulé il y a d'abord des
questions un peu de culture générale sur
différentes thématiques et ensuite il y
a aussi des mini jeux de mémorisation
logique alors vous avez vous avez un
petit peu de tout vous avez de des
réponses
Express donc vous avez un chrono un
chronomètre pour répondre celui qui
réponds le plus vite il automatiquement
le plus de points vous avez le braquage
c'est à dire
voler des points
aux gens qui sont présents c'est des
enfants concurrence si on veut dire et
vous assis aussi le partage de points
c'est assez marrant si vous gagnez vous
êtes obligés de partager les points avec
le choix qui que vous voulez enfin avec
les gens et tout ça ça se passe dans une
même salle ou absolument
sur un sur le même sale d'accord c'est
vraiment studio vous avez des spots vous
avez vous avez la lumière vous avez
c'est vraiment une ambiance de télé et
ça c'était voulu aussi du coup vous avez
vraiment créé un décor immersif avec un
animateur absolument c'est un émulateur
virtuel il est assez marrant parce qu'il
a de la réplique en plus
ça peut mettre des stabilise un petit
peu des gens mais on s'y fait assez
rapidement est-ce que vous allez tenir
peut-être un classement général des
meilleurs pour peut-être une récompense
la récompense c'est très simple vous
avez l'air intéressé Mathilde je sais
pas
je sais que Grégory vous aimez beaucoup
aussi les questions de
culture générale
[Musique]
classement
étant donné que une partie gratuite à
chaque
à chaque groupe et justement ça coûte
combien à peu près alors de 22 à 20
euros et ça dure une heure ça dure entre
40 et 50 minutes suivant les le groupe
qui aura s'il y a des gens qui répondent
rapidement effectivement le temps il se
raccourci et si vous prenez le temps qui
vous a imposé pour répondre
effectivement ça peut durer un peu plus
longtemps laissé comme 9 manches c'est
très long quoi et donc tout à l'heure
vous l'expliquiez même si on est en
train de perdre on peut toujours gagner
à la fin avec ce système de mini jeux
le le côté sympathique si quelqu'un est
moins bon je sais pas dans le sport par
exemple il peut se rattraper sur le
thème qui vont s'afficher s'il est très
fort en série télé il peut choisir à ce
moment-là la série TV et en théorie il
devrait revenir dans les poules est-ce
que vous avez eu des mauvais joueurs
pour le moment où ça va tout le monde va
se faire plaisir pas encore ça va
peut-être venir mais pas encore de toute
façon c'est difficile de tricher là on a
la réponse ou pas répondre effectivement
au hasard est en un qui a 4 buteurs donc
4 possibilités de réponse et bien merci
beaucoup
Idy Adolfo d'être venu en parler avec
nous un plateau merci beaucoup en tout
cas pour votre invitation puis j'espère
vous revoir bientôt et si vous êtes
intéressé par ce quiz Game vous pouvez
avoir toutes les informations sur le
site Internet qui s'affiche juste en
dessous on va ouvrir notre page cinéma
maintenant avec le coup de coeur d'un
professionnel cette semaine c'est le
réalisateur Gauthier Bara qui a choisi
de nous parler de nightcall regardez
bonjour je vais vous parler du film
nightcall sorti en 2014 et c'est un film
réalisé par Dan duroll alors ici nous
sommes sur un film sombre et axé sur les
chasseurs de scoop à Los Angeles avec
comme acteur principal Jake Gillian qui
interprète justement ce chasseur de
scoop et on va avoir vraiment une
performance d'acteurs grandissime son
personnage va évoluer de ranner dans le
film c'est mélangeait avec une
réalisation sombre
un peu nocturne avec un étalonnage un
travail de la lumière
accompagnant cette évolution de
personnage un peu dans l'univers drive
avec Ryan Gosling on est sur une volonté
ici de l'acteur de réussir réussir mais
à quel point il va vraiment vouloir les
de plus en plus loin aller chercher des
détails mais justement jusqu'à quel
point ça je vous laisserai le découvrir
on peut parler du coup de frénésie un
peu de ce qu'ils au frémit du personnage
et on peut vraiment parler je pense
d'une sorte de thriller psychologique
qui est vraiment à découvrir et c'est
vrai qu'on retrouve un peu l'ambiance du
film Drive Grégory tout simplement parce
qu'on voit la voiture et aussi au centre
de ce film les ambiances sombres le
personnage aussi un peu mystérieux Ryan
Gosling dans Drive c'est lui qui porte
le film est un personnage très
mystérieux qu'on découvre aussi au cours
de ce film donc oui il y a des
similitudes forcément on va continuer de
parler cinéma toujours avec vous Grégory
vous nous avez préparé un petit top des
films qui sont sortis aujourd'hui avec
une semaine un peu particulière puisque
il y avait le mardi 1er novembre et il y
a eu des sorties ce mardi 1er novembre
aussi ce mercredi 2 novembre alors parmi
les films à l'affiche cette semaine il y
a celui-ci à quelques jours des
commémorations des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 vous n'aurez pas ma haine
de Killian rideau le film s'appuie sur
le livre éponyme d'Antoine Leiris ce
journaliste français qui a perdu sa
femme lors des attentats du Bataclan
elle acteur pierre deladon change ou le
rôle d'Antoine Léry son le voit évoluer
après le drame on va comprendre comment
il s'est relevé à travers l'amour porté
à son fils l'idée est de montrer que
terroriste qu'ils n'ont pas gagné et
qu'ils n'auront pas sa colère il y a
aussi le nouveau film de Nicolas Bedos
qui sort également aujourd'hui son
quatrième film comme réalisateur il
s'agit de mascara direction la côte
d'azur Mathilde ou Adrien un jeune
gigolo incarné par Pierre Niney ton
couple avec Martha un rôle tenu par
Isabelle Adjani Adrien va tomber sous le
charme de Margaux une manipulatrice et
arnaqueuse ils vont s'associer et cibler
pour une arnaque justement Simon qui est
un agent immobilier joué par François
Cluzet regardez tout de suite un extrait
de la bande-annonce on se voit tous les
soirs on s'appelle tous les jours on
dirait presque un couple moi je suis
heureux
je veux qu'on habite ensemble comme un
vrai couple
[Musique]
le bon profil la terrasse sur 360 degrés
c'est la plus belle classe tout le monde
[Musique]
autre film du cinéma français on passe
au cinéma américain avec Hamsterdam
s'est réalisé par David orelsol
l'histoire de trois amis un docteur une
infirmière et un avocat qui se retrouve
bien malgré eux dans une affaire de
meurtre ça se passe dans les années 30
un casting de choix pour ce film
Christian Bale Margot Robbie John David
Washington retrouve aussi Robert De Niro
Anya Taylor Joy Rami Malek Chris Rock et
même la chanteuse Taylor Swift
Harold je ne sais pas ce que tu es en
train de faire Devillez m'excuser
bonjour il y a le cadavre de blanc dans
une boîte
ce n'est pas le circuit ça il y a même
pas de couvercle ce n'est qu'une vieille
boite en peintre qui va avoir des ennuis
à votre avis
fais-moi plaisir essaye d'être un peu
optimiste et je crois que vous avez un
dernier film pour rester dans l'ambiance
de Halloween absolument c'est un film
intitulé X qui est réalisé par taewest
l'intrigue se déroule à la fin des
années 70 la production d'un film pour
Adulte d'où le titre x veut tourner dans
une maison de campagne dans le Texas
mais tout ne va pas se passer comme
prévu le projet vient même au cauchemar
avec des fantômes et des morts qui
reviennent à la vie beaucoup de sang
âmes sensibles s'abstenir moi je vais
pas aller voir ce film personnellement
je pense que je n'irai pas non plus voir
ce film mais est-ce que vous avez quand
même une préférence Grégory vous n'aurez
pas ma haine je pense qu'il y a attiré
mes préférences et aussi Amsterdam parce
que le casting est croustillant et donne
envie d'aller voir ce film et bien très
bien
une bête de tout poil est-ce que ça vous
dit quelque chose Grégory
comme ça non
d'un film
c'est le poisson jusqu'au 9 juillet vous
pourrez découvrir l'histoire des jouets
animaliers à travers une approche
chronologique d'un don à bascule du 20e
siècle ou encore au bélier à roulettes
de l'Antiquité on regarde le reportage
de Julien Leroy les animaux se donnant
spectacle au Musée du Jouet de Poissy
l'exposition petite bête de tout poil
propose de plonger le spectateur dans
l'histoire des jouets animaliers singes
cochon chat ou encore éléphant une
visite adressée avant tout aux enfants
mais pas seulement c'est aussi destiné à
des gens qui s'intéressent à l'histoire
du jouet à des gens qui veulent
retourner en enfance parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai bain de jouvence
de se promener dans ce musée en
retrouvant des souvenirs en découvrant
des jouets qu'on n'aurait pas imaginé
une exposition pensée de manière
chronologique animaux mécaniques du
début du 20e siècle mais aussi objet de
l'antiquité grâce à un dépôt du musée du
Louvre les gens qui sont en terre cuite
un bélier à roulettes qui vient de
d'Iran mais également des petits ce
qu'on pourrait appeler des ancêtres
duochet qui sont des petits jouets
sonores en forme de hérisson en forme de
cochon en forme d'oiseaux le plus an
[Musique]
continue à plonger vos enfants dans
l'univers animalier divers ateliers et
spectacles sont proposés pendant les
vacances scolaires
et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
je vous propose de jeter un coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
matin dans les Yvelines le ciel sera
dégagé dans l'ensemble sauf à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou les nuages seront
bien présents au niveau des températures
comptées 11 degrés à Rambouillet 12
degrés à Houdan et Versailles et 13
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie dans
l'après-midi prévoyait des averses sur
l'ensemble du département au niveau des
températures et fera 13 à 14 degrés en
moyenne et demain nous fêterons les
Hubert c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi jusqu'au bout
avec nous je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]